mientras los contagios por la viruela
del mono siguen en aumento expertos de
la organización mundial de la salud
intentan enviar un mensaje de calma a la
población
en este brote aún se puede contener y el
objetivo de la organización mundial de
la salud y sus estados miembros es
contener el brote y detenerlo por lo
tanto el riesgo para la población en
general parece ser va a ser similar la
enfermedad que presenta síntomas como
erupciones en la piel y fiebre es muy
común en países de áfrica central y
occidental pero se han confirmado casos
en países de europa américa así como en
australia y medio oriente la propagación
ha empujado a las naciones a evaluar las
reservas de vacunas y sus posibles
tratamientos
en españa' científicos del instituto
carlos tercero lograron obtener el
primer borrador de la secuencia genética
del virus un proceso tomado a partir de
las muestras obtenidas de más de 20
pacientes
la variante de viruela de mono
correspondiente con áfrica occidental-
que es la variante más permítanme menos
maligna o más benigna expresando como
quieran de las dos variantes conocidas
de este virus a pesar de la propagación
y la preocupación en parte del mundo los
funcionarios de salud sostienen que es
muy poco probable que se convierta en
una pandemia por lo pronto de manera
independiente países como francia
recomiendan la vacunación mientras en
alemania las autoridades esperan que con
medidas de cuidado se podrían mantener a
raya el virus pero se preparan para lo
peor por lo que ordenaron 40.000 dosis
de la vacuna contra la enfermedad